[Applause]
okay we're back on overtime face adkins
is back here
and is that
how about the first one to you big guy
what was it like being on celebrity
apprentice twice how has it shaped your
view of trump oh what was it like uh man
it was the most stressful thing i've
ever done if you go on really well if
you go in there and try to win which i
wanted to win you know didn't you win
for my charities i came in second first
time i won the second time
and then the money goes to charity yeah
the first time it was i doubt it
well who's he supposed to i supposed to
but we're talking about trump first time
was for the anaphylaxis network uh food
allergy stuff and the second time was to
the red cross so do you actually become
trump's apprentice if you have to follow
him around no
do you learn at the master no no no no
no but you know he was always good to me
you know right well i mean come on
that means that's because you're a 10.
yeah
i don't know why it was good that he was
just good to me he's good
a lot of people
say the same thing about o.j he was nice
to me yeah
really i mean it's true i i heard that a
lot in the
in the 90s like
oj was
yeah
you know
he was i met him a few times trump
obvious i agree he's
very charming and personable and in
person you know he wants everyone to
like him that's his big thing
it doesn't anyway
john
what would lincoln make of today's
political climate oh lincoln he'd
recognize it tragically um
right you know
he
one of the things that interests me
about what's going on is
you do have people who
think the system can't be saved right uh
and so
that's not unlike the abolitionists in
the 1850s actually burned the
constitution william lloyd garrison
burned the constitution on in 1854
called it an agreement with death and a
covenant with hell
and said
abolitionists should leave the
constitutional experiment you had
secessionists from our part of the world
who did the same
it was lincoln and it was frederick
douglass who said this is the last best
hope
and if we don't if we can't get this
right
then it's only going to be monarchy it's
only going to be aristocracy
and so
he confronted this problem of again not
just differing on what the facts were
but differing on what
human nature was who was included in the
declaration of independence
declaration of independence to him was
scripture
and it was about interpreting the
ongoing meaning of that
and i think that my sense is we've
always been if you think of the moments
we commemorate
the moments where we
think if we're being if we say openly
this is where i'd like to go back to
there are moments where
we expanded the definition and
understanding and access to the
mainstream not when we constricted it
and that's what lincoln was about
so you had mentioned before in the show
about uh 1965. yeah where
where are you two summoners where is the
south
how different is the south i mean i
think
obviously we we have to start it it's
very different than it was in 1965.
not completely healed
in any way
but how different
would you say
southern states are from where it was
back then
i mean you wouldn't have done a a duet
with snoop dogg
1964. no
i feel like
i don't think snoop was alive but uh uh
but i mean i feel like that says a lot
well i don't know you know the way i
look at it now i'm i'm
reading a book right now that was
written by david goldfield who's a
history professor at the university of
north carolina it's called america a
flame and he he starts in 1830s and he
leads up to the civil war
chronologically going through all these
facts and everything but he kind of
wraps it all up at the end just prior to
before the war started
concluding that once
each side is pointing at the other and
calling them evil yep once you get to
that point
if you truly believe that
then compromise is off the table
that's where we are though you have no
integrity if you because you how can you
make a deal with the devil if you truly
believe that right and to me it seems
like
damn it it kind of seems like that's
where we're headed people are pointing
the finger at one another and saying
you're evil and once you once you cross
that line
it's hard to walk that one back it is
and i think we've crossed it the
well you know
lincoln's inside about that was
and he said this on his trip to
washington
he
said it on the ohio border in cincinnati
he said if we were over in kentucky
we would probably feel as they feel
we are not morally superior we have a
different view of right and wrong
and
he
insisted not it the civil war was not of
both sides problems like january 6 was
not a both sides thing
it was a case where
because of economic and
cultural
convictions
my native region our native region
decided that black people were less than
human and were not included in the
declaration of independence
and lincoln
said no
that in fact they are
and the question
the fact that you have to clap for that
this is thinking this is bad i was
thinking this way you know
human equality
you know three three cheers for we the
people um
the
the dangerous thing and i said it
earlier and i i did it with care the
problem with saying this is like the
1850s this goes to the book you're
reading
is how did the decade end
with 750 000 people
dying i grew up on a civil war
battlefield you live basically on one
right you're near carton and all that
um
and
there has to be
a way for 60 or more of us to say
we're going to mediate our differences
and not do battle over them
and that's i really do believe that
number's about right 34 of the country's
always wrong uh that's the number that
supported joe mccarthy a year after he'd
been censured
right so
and we've only had three presidents
who've gotten 60
since world war ii uh johnson in 64.
nixon in 72 reagan in 84.
biden's margin one of the many ironies
and somewhat in tragedies of the 2000
the 2020 election is that was a
perfectly respectable
win in a polarized era it was better
than truman's right in 48 it was better
than nixon's in 68 better than kennedy's
in 60.
uh
better than either of bill clinton's
better than w
either time
and so it's
i don't want to say that we adjust our
expectations downward but i do think to
go to your last point one of the things
history can tell you is
total victory is not possible in
politics and so you you have to figure
out what does victory look like and
if we're talking about another civil war
it's not possible there either because
at least in the first one everyone who
thought one way was on one side of the
border whereas now we're all marbled in
with each other yeah and this is what i
was saying in the beginning the show
about we're turning into red states
versus blue states and people don't feel
comfortable acting shall we say in a red
way
would someone wear a maga hat
to a restaurant in los angeles i think
it was a curb your enthusiasm episode he
did that right right
you know right would you wear a hillary
clinton t-shirt not you
but but like you know what i mean and i
don't want to live in that country
because i don't want to all like i'm
basically in a i'm in a blue state and
basically side with them but i don't
want to have to go along with everything
blue no because sometimes they're not
right in my view and that's okay
and i don't want to have to choose sides
like which side am i on i don't want to
be
i want to be in a country that has both
in every place well it should be
i just think
it just it has to be both but both have
to accept the rule of law right
otherwise you know the things to say to
business people i think uh
i mean i have lots of i mean we live in
tennessee so when we say we have
conservative friends we're being
redundant right uh
so i i have a ton of people
who
are republicans who don't want trump
and then they'll say but biden's
spending too much money
like you don't get to say the second
part
until you fix the first
and i didn't feel this way and you
alluded to it i didn't feel this way
until the election stuff
yeah i think when you launch an attack
on the capitol
and you undermine
the one thing we've got that enables
this other experiment to go on and i'm
gonna say the other side's perfect but i
think a lot of republicans if you agree
with this i think a lot of republicans
who don't like trump
want forgiveness but they don't want to
repent
well we don't update i ain't asked
forgiveness for [ __ ]
[Laughter]
right and you shouldn't have to i didn't
know anything but you it's not personal
it's policy exactly
no it's not so
and you just don't want to have to move
because moving sucks all right
you know what
i i'm too old moving sucks
and you can't do it i mean i'm stuck
here i i looked at it because of the
fires here and stuff like that yeah and
we got things here that are really you
know i couldn't get my solar hooked up
for three years i mean the regulations
the taxes can a man get a glass of water
i mean you know it's like
not one river in this state not one drop
of water should ever make it to the
ocean without going through a
hydroelectric dam first
[Applause]
yes
sorry did you
i was gonna say it is personal i think
uh trump made a lot of things personal
and when we talk about the division in
this country we can't talk about it as
if it's a meteorological phenomenon that
just happened
right
that's true there were certain things
that were done by certain people in
certain institutions trump among them
very consciously to divide this country
to prey upon the fissures that already
existed and to make them wider and wider
and wider to the point where we can't
see each other across them
so it's not just like oh my this has
happened
this was done
in many ways on purpose by trump
that's what demigods do yeah and so when
we say it's not personal it is personal
and i do think people who supported
trump and who enabled trump do have
something to apologize for and do have a
lot to repent from
a man a man who
a man who calls countries [ __ ]
countries who tells
congress people of color to go back to
where they came from who
who calls women pigs who makes fun of
their menstrual cycles i could go on and
on and on
that you know and that people still
follow him and think that's still okay
and that they you know that
that that is that is something that we
have to talk about you can answer that
if you want to but i would say most of
the people i know who voted for trump
say the biggest mistake liberals make is
thinking i like him
it doesn't matter if you still you're
not excited
what they're saying is you get two
choices in this country i would never
vote for donald trump nobody was harder
on donald trump than me i have the
records to prove it and i
and i am
and i have all did you vote for him of
course not there you go but you didn't
vote for him but it's a little more
nuanced than that it's a little more
nuanced than that i understand why
people who who make the decision to vote
which most people do based on not who i
like the best but who i hate the least
ago there are things that are going on
said and has done are not bad enough
to keep you from voting for him to which
means which means you're
more okay with him being in power and
him having the nuclear codes and him
having control of the army and the
department of justice not you the
general you that means you're okay with
that or you're more okay with that than
the other guy no matter what he said no
matter who what he's done
right it's one of the great problems
with i think with a lot of commentary
that unfolding commentary presidential
politics is not a referendum
nobody came to your point and said do
you want donald trump to be president no
it's do you want him or do you want
hillary clinton
and by the same token nobody nobody came
to the country and said do you want joe
biden to be president
no
do you want president biden do you want
biden or do you want trump
and then we forget that within 24 hours
and it's it's as if we just this single
singular person
had been
packaged and chosen it's a choice
it's always a comparison absolutely but
it means that all these things were not
bad enough
for people to dissuade them from voting
but it depends on what your priority in
my life exactly my last special i was
talking about the fact that to me the
two biggest issues are democracy and the
environment those are my two big one and
two but i don't have kids
i know people who say i have kids and i
don't like it when they come home and
say uh they divided the class today into
oppressors and oppressed
and if i change my sex i don't have to
tell my parents
there's [ __ ] like that going on that
makes people go you know i agree donald
trump is a creep
he is everything wrong that could be
stuffed into one man
but i have these other considerations
that's all and that's why you you know
you seem like you have such contempt
for half the country i don't think
that's going to get us where we need to
go because as to your point i think
we've crossed this line and now the
question is how do we walk it back
how do we walk it back from
[Applause]
i hate you so much
that i can't live with you and we have
to live with each other there's not an
apartment where we can put the tape down
the middle of it yeah
yeah we have to find a way
okay thank you very much everybody that
was
good of you to put up with that
you